تقول طالبان إنها تريد أن ترى
علاقات سلمية وإيجابية مع جميع
البلدان بما في ذلك الولايات المتحدة ،
لكن هذه الآفاق تضاءلت بشكل كبير.
لقد
أوضحنا أن حكومة أفغانستان
لم تكن على علم بوصول أو
وجود السيد الزواهيدي وكابول حتى الآن
لم نتمكن من إثبات
حقيقة أن السيد الظواهري كان
بالفعل كأس الرئيس ليس '  هذا الأمر
مخيف أكثر على الرغم من أن فكرة
أنك تدعي أنه
زعيم القاعدة كانت موجودة هنا في
وسط المدينة ولم تكن تعرف عنها
مرة أخرى ، فنحن نؤكد أن فكرة أنه كان
حاضرًا هنا ولكن حتى  إذا كانت
هذه الأنواع من الحوادث تحدث
في كل مكان في العالم لكنها في الحقيقة
لا أعني كيف يمكن للولايات المتحدة أن تثق
في قيادة طالبان رغم أنها ستبقى
وفية لوعدها بأنها لن
تسمح لـ Sanctuar  سنمنح
للجماعات الإرهابية
إذا نظرنا إلى اتفاقية الدوحة ، فإن
المواد
التي تحدد
التزامات حكومة أفغانستان
قد تم الوفاء بها جميعًا ، وإذا نظرنا
إلى الالتزامات التي تعهدت بها الولايات
المتحدة الأمريكية للأسف.
لم يتم الوفاء بمقالة واحدة
ولكننا نأمل ونستمر في
حث الولايات المتحدة على الالتزام بهذا
الاتفاق